there are a bunch of different debates
about the medical procedure known as
abortion and the very backwards
perspective of Texas Republicans on this
issue is potentially putting on the
table the idea of sentencing to death
women who have abortions and the gist of
it would be like this Texas House bill
586 would criminalize abortion and it
would designate abortion a homicide
if you designate abortion a homicide
that means that you need to look at what
the potential punishments are for
homicide in the state of Texas where you
can get the death penalty for homicide
therefore a woman who gets an abortion
could conceivably get the death penalty
and it's the the it's just stunning how
their position is effectively they
believe abortion is burr is murder and
they hate killing so much that if you
have an abortion they'll kill you which
seems quite backwards and that is also
related to why we should be opposed to
the death penalty which is a topic for
for a different day now as far as this
house bill in Texas becoming the law the
debate so far was in the Texas House
Judiciary Committee so the next step
would be the full Texas House would need
to debate it and then we'll see where it
goes but I've been reading many comments
online and there are some really
ignorant responses to this proposal one
is who cares Texas women can just go to
another state problem solved well first
of all I don't know if you've ever
looked at a map of Texas but going to
another state can be an eight-hour drive
each way to the border of another state
depending on where you're going and the
point of all this is that the movement
to make abortions more difficult to
access scarier to consider getting more
expensive potentially criminal time
consuming most of these Republicans are
total hypocrites and if their daughter
got pregnant they would immediately go
and get them an abortion some of them
wouldn't but many of them would and
there's a broader goal here because many
of these outrageous anti-choice laws are
attempting to create a situation where
they get something to the supreme
okay I talk probably every other show
about how if we had any misunderstanding
about the importance of who gets to
select Supreme Court justices before the
2016 election I hope that every single
person in the audience has been
disabused of that misunderstanding at
this point in time the goal here is not
that Republicans think a lot of these
outrageous anti-choice laws are going to
pass what they are trying to do is to
create the grounds for appeal after
appeal to eventually get something
abortion related back to the Supreme
Court at a time when the right probably
accurately thanks to Donald Trump being
president and and having one of the
strongest majorities on the Supreme
Court that they've had in a long time
the right is counting on the idea that
if they can get something abortion
related to the Supreme Court maybe they
can actually make a move in the
direction of overturning roe v wade and
then you open the door completely to
States much more aggressively banning
abortion potentially even altogether
within their states and in the end
remember these limits when these limits
are placed on abortion in practice they
restrict poor people from getting
abortions people who can't pay for the
discretion of a private clinic people
who can't take time off from work to
drive to another state to get an
abortion in every state we know that
when you make abortions illegal or more
difficult to obtain it doesn't actually
reduce the abortion rate and number two
it disproportionately is impacting poor
people and rich people as is the case in
many places my home birth country of
Argentina where abortion has been
criminal for a very long time it's
always known that if you have money you
go to a private clinic and that's it and
that is why this disproportionately
affects poor people and is another
element of the sort of class warfare
that we have been seeing along medical
lines economic lines social lines etc
for a very long time and meanwhile we
have in the United States compared to
other wealthy countries one of the
higher infant more
tality rates and instead of focusing on
that in states that have disastrous
health care like Texas they're looking
at making getting an abortion criminal
which could subject the mother
potentially to the death penalty it's
stunning and disgusting and there is no
reason whatsoever to think that it's
going to change anytime soon
because they are emboldened by one of
the strongest conservative majorities in
the Supreme Court in a long time today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skills fairs
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]